All right. So, anything else brother or
let me know. If there is a third
question,
basically I've started reading the Bible
in uh November 2024. I always was a
believer of God being brought up in a
Christian family. Never practiced too
much. But I grew closer because of uh
health implications within my family.
And I found myself praying every single
day. A close friend of mine told me to
start reading the Bible. And from there,
my life completely changed. So, one of
the verses that stuck with me and to
this day I have memorized and basically
every single time that there was this
problem in my family, I always went back
to this verse. I wanted to ask you
because you're very knowledgeable in the
Bible if there were any new angles that
I could have uh understood this verse
here. It's Mark uh 11 chapter 11 verse
22. Have faith in God. Jesus answered, I
tell you the truth. If anyone says to
this mountain will throw yourself into
the sea and does not doubt in his heart
but believes that what he says will
happen it will be done for him.
Therefore I tell you whatever you ask
for in prayer believe that you have
received it and it will be given to you
in full something like that. So I wanted
to ask you because I've read it like a
hundred times. Is there any like uh
context that I need to know about it or
anything that I can learn that God will
answer any prayer even if it's against
his will.
I don't think you heard me
that will God answer any prayer even if
it's against his will.
I don't believe we need to Lord the Lord
has his own path and we do our best
faith in God answering a prayer even if
I'm praying against his
will. Uh I don't think so.
You have to even think about that. So
God, I want to have three women all day,
all night. Can you answer that prayer?
And I'm going to keep praying until No.
No. I because you were lagging or I was
lagging. So that's why I didn't hear the
question.
Faith and praying that God will even
answer something that is against his
will. Is that the context?
No.
So that statement of our Lord is not
implying whatever I pray for, if I keep
praying for it and do not budge, God
will give me whatever I ask. Because God
will never answer a prayer that's
against his will, that goes against his
character, goes against his command,
and that will be harmful to you.
So, we don't take Jesus's words in
isolation. We take Jesus' words in
context because he said a lot about
prayer even here. Let's see what kind of
prayers does God answer. You ready? Yes.
You sure? Yes.
All
right. Okay. 1 John
3:21-22. Beloved, if our heart does not
condemn us, we have confidence before
God. And whoever we ask, we receive from
it because we keep his
commandments and do the things that are
pleasing in his sight. That's the
condition. What if you're not keeping
his commandments and pleasing in his
sight? Then will he answer your prayer?
No. Because your prayer is an
abomination. Disgusting to him, right?
Mhm. Yeah. Because he hates the prayers
of the wicked. Mhm.
You want me there? Yes, 100%. Here's
another one. John 5:14-15. And this is
the confidence which we have before him
that if we ask anything according to his
[Applause]
will, he hears
us. So what if you're praying against
his
will? We should pray for our eyes and to
gain the wisdom in order to follow his
path and what he wants.
Okay. But what if you're praying against
his will?
We Let's see. What is he going to do?
Answer you? No. So when Jesus says you
have faith of a Muslim state, you'll
tell this mountain move and move. You
don't take Jesus words out of context
when you have to see all that he said
about prayer. Yes. If I am in line with
God's will and I'm doing all I can to
acknowledge my sin and turn away from it
and obey him, the more righteous I am,
the more in line I am with his will, the
more my prayers will be in line with his
will and the more God will delight in my
prayers and that will then be fulfilled.
So here's the condition and this is the
confidence which we have before him that
if we ask anything according to his will
he hears us and if we know that he hears
us in whatever we ask we know that we
have the request which we have asked for
him and now if I were to take just verse
15 and if we know that he hears us in
whatever he asks see ask whatever you
want even if it's against his will no
because the verse before it says
whatever I ask that's in line with his
perfect will for my
life that's condition number Condition
number two. Yes. 1 John 3:21-22.
Beloved, if our heart can does not
condemn us, we have confidence before
God. Whatever we ask, we receive from
him condition because we keep his
commandments and do the things that are
pleasing his sight. What if I break his
commandments and do things that are
displeasing to him?
Then will he answer me? No, he won't
answer you. So that's the condition of
Mark 11:22.
So any other question? You have one more
so we can wrap it up.